Announcer: Three...
Announcer: Two...
Announcer: One...
Announcer: Blast off!
Announcer: To a new beginning
Announcer: beyond the stars.
America's famous for
the notion that
it's the land of opportunity.
Americans promising
more than we can deliver.
That's the center
of Hello Tomorrow.
Announcer: Start living your brighter tomorrow
Announcer: today!
The show is about
the American dream
and how askew it can go.
This show is so unique.
I have a hard time describing it.
Hello Tomorrow is about
a bunch of salesmen.
They're selling timeshares
for a property on the moon
called the Brightside.
It's a futuristic
story told in a retro way.
Automatically I was interested.
You're introduced to this world
through Jack Billings.
He's got a sales team
of misfits and vagabonds.
Shirley absolutely runs this business.
Incredibly shrewd,
very capable,
perfect counterpart to Jack.
They're giving people
an opportunity to hope
for a better future.
The Brightside.
That's a place for real people.
To start fresh,
unwind, retire.
It is 1950's retro future.
The sets, cars, clothing.
There's something so fun
about imagining a world that's
never been seen before.
We built a lot of the robots practically.
You've got puppeteers.
Remote control.
They make a lot of noise.
I have so many emotional scenes,
where in the background
is this little one eyed tin can
Zizz. Zizz.
The beginning of the show
is defined by such optimism.
I'm out delivering smiles.
[ SMASH ]
And then very quickly
it is made clear
there is a lot more
ominous undertones.
It's kind of funny
how good things can be
without the truth getting in the way.
And action!
I found it incredibly
entertaining to imagine a world
that's talking about
the spirit of American salesmanship.
Jack, compulsively,
seeks happiness
and to satisfy anyone in front of him.
That sense of hopefulness as
lie upon lie begins
to crumble down
I've never seen
it put on page before.
We rely on storytelling
to make sense of our world.
In this alternative future
nothing is any different.
All the gadgets break.
At a certain point,
your bartender robot might
be able to serve you a
beer from its belly,
but there might be a little
bit of motor oil in it.
Hey there, fella.
My eyes are up here.
We promise perfection
and what we deliver is human.
I'm excited for audiences
to see the chemistry on set.
That can't be on there.
We do a lot of laughing
but it's quite emotional
at the same time.
I will burn this whole
place to the ground.
This is about what we
still all wrestle with.
What's the truth?
What's a lie?
What do I actually believe in?
It is funny,
and thoughtful,
and odd.
But everybody in their own way
is trying to be a better human.